PRESIDENT BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS
THROWING GASOLINE ON THE
INFLATION DUMPSTER FIVE,
$740 BILLION INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT WILL UNLEASH AN AVALANCHE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY ON COALITION-LIST
ITEMS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT WILL ALSO JACK UP TAXES
DURING THE RECESSION.
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY WILL PAY
THE PRICE AND THE MIDTERMS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN -- SAYS THIS IS
A MAJOR WIN.
>> President Biden: EXPECT YOU
TO HELP, I'M GOING TO NEED YOU
TO.
FOR EXAMPLE, NO STATE --
MEDICARE -- $2,000 TO GO.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
SOME OF US, IT WON'T KICK IN FOR
A LITTLE BIT, BUT IT'S ALL GOOD.
WHEN YOU SIT DOWN AT THE END OF
THE MONTH, YOU WILL SEE MORE
BILLS.
>> IF YOU LOVE GETTING AUDITED,
LISTEN UP: DEMOCRATS WILL SEND
IRS GOONS FOR YOUR BANK ACCOUNT.
AFTER GIVING THEM $80 BILLION TO
RAMP UP ENFORCEMENT, HIRING
87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS.
GET THIS: THE AGENCY WILL END UP
WITH MORE STAFFERS THAN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, FBI, AND
BORDER PATROL COMBINED.
DEMOCRATS THINK THEY ARE CLEVER
BY CALLING IT THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT, BUT EVEN
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS SEES ME
THAT CHARADE.
>> I WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THE SO-CALLED INFLATION
ACT WE ARE DEBATING THIS
EVENING.
I SAY SO-CALLED BECAUSE,
ACCORDING TO THE CBO AND OTHER
ECONOMIC ORGANIZATIONS, IT WILL
HAVE A MINIMAL IMPACT ON
INFLATION.
>> SENATOR SCOTT -- YOU ARE NOT
BERNIE SANDERS, EXCUSE ME.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU WERE THERE WHEN THE SAUSAGE
WAS BEING MADE.
WHAT'S THE MOST WORRYING THING
ABOUT THIS.
>> TO START THE SHOW -- THAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THIS ALSO INCLUDES THE PENTAGON.
IF YOU HAVE BALL FOUR OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER, YOU WILL
STILL HAVE A BIGGER IRS AND
SCARIEST PART FOR OUR VIEWERS IS
THERE'S 8,087,000 NEW EMPLOYEES
HUNTING FOR TAXES FROM PEOPLE
MAKING LESS THAN $200,000.
IT'S NOT THE BILLIONAIRES AND
MILLIONAIRES.
IT IS MIDDLE-INCOME FAMILIES,
LOW INCOME FAMILIES, AND
ENTREPRENEURS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO KEEP EMPLOYEES
WORKING AND INVEST IN THEIR
FUTURE.
>> WHEN THEY NAMED THIS THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WERE
YOU JUST SNICKERING?
>> I CALL IT THE INFLATION
SUBDUCTION ACT.
BERNIE SANDERS, TIM SCOTT, TED
CRUZ, WHEN THEY ARE ON THE SAME
SIDE, THAT TELLS YOU THAT
WHATEVER THEY ARE SELLING WE ARE
NOT BUYING >> GREG GUTFELD, YOUR
REACTION TO THE WEEKEND?
>> WHENEVER CON MAN HAS ALIASES,
AND THAT'S A TIP-OFF.
HE HAS CHANGED HIS NAME MORE
TIME THAN KANYE WEST.
[LAUGHTER]
IT WAS INFLATION, THEN CLAIMANT,
THEN HEALTH CARE, THEN TAX
POLICY, THAN CLIENT.
THIS HAS MORE FACES THAN
NANCY PELOSI.
BUT, THEY DO THIS SO THEY CAN
KEEP YOU OFF THE SCENT,
OVERWHELM YOU.
I DON'T THINK THIS BILL PASSED:
IT JUST DOOR EVERYONE DOWN.
WE HAVE A HARD TIME FOLLOWING
THIS.
SPENDING BILLS ARE LIKE
CELL PHONE PLANS.
SO MANY OPTIONS, DIRECTIONS,
FALSE FLAG.
WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT THE BETTER
CELL PHONE PLAN.
ARE YOU A LAWYER?
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE NEED MORE MECHANICS AND
POLITICS.
ATTORNEYS TAKE THE SIMPLEST
THING AND LABEL IT WITH
COMPLEXITY SO IT KEEPS ALL THE
SIDES BUSY.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE ADDING
ALL THESE IRS AGENTS SHOWS YOU
THE FEEDBACK LOOP.
IT SHOWS YOU HOW THEY PAY FOR
THEIR FANTASY.
ONE APP OF THE BILL ARE THE
FANTASIES, AND THE OTHER HALF
HAS TO STEAL TO PAY FOR IT.
IT'S LIKE A NEVER ENDING SYSTEM,
A CONFIGURATION THAT CAN GO ON
FOREVER.
ANYTIME YOU WANT TO PUT MORE
MONEY IN, YOU JUST HIRE MORE IRS
AGENTS.
AMERICANS DON'T NEED A DOUBLING
OF THE IRS.
CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL.
IT'S EASIER TO GO AFTER
WHITE-COLLAR CRIMINALS THAN
PEOPLE WHO SHOOT BACK AT YOU.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WE WANT TO
PUT AWAY.
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO SAY "I
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY
LAWYER FEES, I WILL JUST GIVE
WHAT I CAN.
>> IS THIS THE FUTURE WAS
INSULATION --
IS THIS THE FUTURE OF
LEGISLATION?
>> THIS IS WHAT WE ARE USED TO.
EVERYTHING IS NOT AS IT SEEMS.
THIS WHOLE ADMINISTRATION IS
ABOUT "DON'T BELIEVE YOUR LYING
EYES.
JUST BECAUSE IT MAKES SENSE TO
YOU DOESN'T MEAN IT'S TRUE."
I THINK THEY SHOULD CALL IT THE
ELECTION SUBDUCTION ACT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
CONVINCE AMERICANS THAT THIS
WILL HELP YOU WITH INFLATION.
WON'T HAVE ANY IMPACT ON
INFLATION, AND JUST LIKE THE
PRESIDENT SAID, HE JUST SAID YOU
WILL HAVE MORE MONEY TO PAY YOUR
BILLS.
HOGWASH.
PRICES OF EVERYTHING ARE STILL
THE SAME.
41% OF 1%, OR WHATEVER IT IS.
>> THE CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET.
>> CBO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
>> I SAY THE TRUTH, UNLIKE MY
DEMOCRATIC FRIEND.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY WANT TO SICK THE IRS ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SENATOR, I DID NOT REALIZE THAT
THE PRIMARY PEOPLE THEY ARE
GOING AFTER OUR MAKING LESS THAN
$200,000.
>> 90% OF THE REVENUE COMES FROM
PEOPLE WITH LESS THAN $200,000,
THAT'S THEIR PROJECTION.
>> IF THEY DEALT WITH CRIME, AND
INSTEAD PUT 87,000 MORE COPS ON
THE STREET UNTIL THEY COULD SAY
"WE DID NOT MEAN IT WHEN WE SAID
TO FUND THE POLICE.
WE WILL PUT 87,000 MORE COPS ON
THE STREET."
NO, THEY ARE LOOKING TO MAKE UP
CRIMINALS.
IT'S A BAD SITUATION.
THEY WILL HAMMER SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND WE ARE GOING TO
SUFFER.
>> SO, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, CRIME,
INFLATION, AND THIS RANKS DOWN
NEAR THE BOTTOM.
HOW CAN THE DEMOCRATS SAY THIS
IS A WIN?
>> I HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
VIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JOE MANCHIN, YOUR
COLLEAGUES --
THESE TWO BIG DEMOCRATS HAVE
LONG BEEN OPPOSED TO THE BUILD
BACK BETTER ACT.
HE THOUGHT THAT INFLATION WAS A
DRIVING FORCE.
HE WAS AN ARBITER OF THIS BILL.
EITHER HE IS A LIAR, FIBBING A
BIT, OR IS CONCERNED WITH
INFLATION LARRY SUMMERS WAS A
HUGE CRITIC OF SPENDING, EVEN
BACK DURING THE COVID AREA.
HE HAS DECIDED THAT THIS BILL
SATISFIES MANY OF HIS CONCERNS
THAT THEY WON'T HAVE THAT UPWARD
PRESSURE IMPACT ON INFLATION.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, IF
BERNIE SANDERS IS ON ONE SIDE OF
SOMETHING SAYING THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY BEING SPENT, AND --
I'M A MODERATE DEMOCRAT.
THAT'S WHERE I WANT TO BE AT.
IF THEY TURN OUT TO BE WRONG, WE
SHOULD ADMIT THAT THEY ARE
WRONG.
THIS BILL DOES FOUR THINGS.
IT LOWERS THE DEBT $300 BILLION.
IT LOWERS DRUG COSTS.
ONE OF THE KEY DRIVERS IN
HOUSEHOLDS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE THE COST PEOPLE TO
PAY FOR DRUGS.
MY SON HAD A PRESCRIPTION THIS
WEEKEND.
THANK GOD I WAS ABLE TO AFFORD
IT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO.
TWO, IT INCREASES DOMESTIC --
PRODUCTION.
IT DOES A LOT ON CLIMATE CHANGE,
BUT THERE'S ALSO NO WAY THAT
JOE MANCHIN WOULD NOT WANT MORE
COAL, FRACKING, DRILLING.
>> THERE IS ROOM FOR NUCLEAR AS
WELL >> THIS IS PERHAPS NOT
ENOUGH.
THIS INCREASES TAXES ON THE
WEALTHIEST AMERICANS.
WE CAN DISAGREE WITH THAT.
>> THEY HAD TO PAY FOR SOME OF
THIS.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SAY
NOW -- RAISING TAXES.
>> YOU MAY BE IN THIS CATEGORY.
>> YOU WERE INVITED TO THIS
HOUSE?
>> THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, AND
NOW YOU HAVE TO DO OTHER THINGS.
YOU ARE ON A ROLL, DON'T LET UP.
>> WE ARE ON A ROLL, WE ARE THE
MEAT ON THAT SANDWICH.
HAROLD, I'M GOING TO CRUSH YOU
RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS WHATEVER, THE CLEAN
ENERGY BILL.
WHAT DID WE GET?
REMEMBER, THE BEAUTIFUL BILLION
DOLLARS LIGHT RAIL SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAROLD, THIS IS
HOW IT FEELS TO BE UTTERLY
HUMILIATED.
>> IF I TURN OUT TO BE WRONG, I
WILL COME BACK AND SAY I'M